If you've seen the Rat Queen from Netflix's
"Cabinet of Curiosities," you'll probably never
forget it. Here's how the creative team brought
the creature to life — without digital effects.
Halloween may have come and gone this
year, but "Guillermo del Toro's Cabinet
of Curiosities" isn't going anywhere. You
can still have a spooky good time with it.
If you're unfamiliar with the Netflix series,
it's an anthology of eight spooky tales,
in the vein of "Tales From the Crypt"
or "Masters of Horror." A brief glance
through the cast list proves that,
while big celebrity talent might not
show up for all horror projects,
everyone shows up for del Toro.
The curiosities vary drastically, featuring
everything from demonic storage units to
alien-infested corpses to ghostly forests
to rodents of unusual size. Fortunately,
only one of those abominations was
brought to life with only practical
effects. Unfortunately, it was the
rat, and that thing is terrifying.
In the second episode, simply titled "Graveyard
Rats," a down-on-his-luck grave robber played
by David Hewlett can't seem to hold
onto any trinkets that he unearths
because an ungodly swarm of rats snatches
the treasures away the moment he finds them.
"As you can see, I'm at my wit's end!"
He can't seem to really take the hint, though,
and continues to rob graves. Eventually,
he stumbles across what the show's art team
casually referred to as the Rat Queen. While
the term "queen" may imply an aura of grace,
the Rat Queen has none of that. It does have
what you might call some royal authority,
though. It's a truly intimidating creature.
She's a monstrous beast of an animatronic puppet
with bulbous, milky eyes and wispy fur that hardly
covers her mottled skin. Next to Hewlett, the
Rat Queen puppet is more than human-sized;
it's basically the size of a horse. Vincenzo
Natali, who directed the episode, told "Newsweek"
that the Rat Queen was something of a miracle,
even if it looked like a nightmare. He said:
"It is the first puppet that I've worked with that
actually works 100 percent. It was
really quite something to behold."
"The desire was always to make our creatures
with physical, tangible materials."
Natali went on to describe all the benefits
of sticking with practical effects,
because it gave Hewlett something to act
against, which CGI wouldn't do. He said,
"The queen rat was so shocking, and they
had it right in David's face. I think it
was better than if he was acting to a tennis
ball on a grip stand, and it's thrilling.
There's something about watching that on a
monitor, when everything's actually in the
frame and it's happening in real time, that
is exhilarating for everybody. Then you get
a subtlety in terms of how that creature
interacts with the light and even little
things like the way its whiskers move and so on,
that would be very difficult to do digitally."
The team at Spectral Motion, the company
that created the Rat Queen puppet,
clearly created something very lifelike. But it
can't move on its own, at least not yet. For now,
at least, the creature requires a
helping human hand. Natali said,
"The puppeteers were fantastic and we
had a great time. I had a great time
directing the puppet — like the puppet is a
character, it is an actor on that set. It's
kind of thrilling for me as a director
to interact with a creature like that."
At least he was having fun.